foreign
people welcome to a special Thanksgiving
episode of honest trailer commentaries
uh I am Spencer J Gilbert my favorite
Thanksgiving food is really sweet potato
pie I've been getting into recently
um or mashed potatoes of gravy what's
yours Lana Danielle
oh um so I am uh very partial to the
this like banana pudding that we make it
always used to be like oh it's like a
secret family recipe and then one day I
found it on the back of a box of vanilla
wafers and I was like that's my secret
family that's the secret family I was
gonna ask there's there's Nilla wafers
in there right oh oh my dude I'm like
making custard from scratch and then uh
when I want to do like the easier
version I have a copycat recipe for the
Magnolia Bakery banana that's a good one
that's a good one Lon what do you got I
I'll tell you I I love uh stuffing but
what makes it even more it's like it's a
special like you only really get
stuffing around Thanksgiving like like
it's not a it's not just a like oh it's
April I'm gonna have a big bowl of
stuffing like so I think the Rarity of
it in the calendar like the fact that
you only really have it is part of the
Thanksgiving meal or Thanksgiving
leftovers makes it that much more
special so yeah that's the thing I
probably well there you go if this seems
a little uh insular and U.S Centric uh
so is this movie
um
all right forgive us uh so we we did
Pocahontas um I was shocked that we
haven't done it before uh yeah really
big massive Disney movie that they
thought was gonna be the hit uh instead
of The Lion King um they were they were
banking on this one being tough I think
what let me just stop you right there
what did they think was the appeal
that's what's confusing to me like
watching through it I'm like it's not
only that it's not good
um spoiler alert but it's like uh I
don't know what they thought the hook
was that that like kids and families and
people were gonna love about it I think
that they probably thought that it was
more four quadrant because you have like
the the princess stuff and you have the
history stuff
um like that that brings in the parents
and the and maybe it's gonna get like
Civil War dads yes or dads and daughters
that's what it is like yeah genocide for
the dads and romance for the girl says I
feel like even the the most kind-hearted
evaluation of the songs if you were
listening to this in the like High
Disney Renaissance like and like you've
got Elton John going down the hall
you've got you know menkin and all that
other stuff you listen there's like not
bangers like clearly the mining song as
well sure but I do think that certainly
Vanessa Williams version of Colors of
the Wind is is Iconic um that's that's a
top 10 Disney song for me
um but yeah so it sorry if you haven't
seen this show before we're going to
talk about Pocahontas
um and then we're gonna do uh uh some
deleted scenes that we got and we'll
answer your questions so type those in
the live chat we'll tease you with next
week's honest trailer
um sorry I didn't mean to I didn't mean
to break this oh no no please if this is
anyone's first episode I'm sorry that's
weird let's just start at the beginning
so you know I really you're not gonna
catch any of the Easter eggs
yeah I was a kid when it came out so it
was like yeah it was fine but I I do
distinctly remember being like I don't
know if I like I'm gonna stick with my
Aerials and my bells yeah
um I was um emphatically not a Disney
person growing up I was uh I I got
hooked on the The Looney Tunes to 90s
MTV Nickelodeon pipeline I I just missed
Disney altogether
um so it's been fun I'd actually never
seen Pocahontas um going back and seeing
what all the fuss was about not much not
a lot going on in this movie pretty
bland
um but I knew I effing knew it that we
had a joke at the beginning of the
trailer and we'll start playing it soon
where we call the output of a decade's
worth of Disney Animation garbage and I
knew and Lon you were you you saw this
coming and you had us remove you know
Treasure Planet or I tried to walk us
back from the breakup
no matter what no matter what there are
Die Hard Defenders of every Disney movie
no matter how mediocre you had you had
Atlantis the Lost Empire in the first
run of that and I was like they're going
to kill us like that's like the most
popular Disney movie among a certain
subset of fans so like I was like that
one strike it from the record you can
say that about
apparently there's a huge Meet the
Robinsons fandom right but but no people
tell me way more about Brother Bear than
I think I need to yeah but please know
Disney hardcores I did I threw myself on
on the tracks of the Big Thunder
Railroad on behalf of Atlantis the Lost
Empire I was like get that get that one
out of the list because that we're gonna
get strung up in the town square wow
well uh more thoughts on that to come
let's let's watch the Oz trailer for
Pocahontas
[Music]
from the studio that dominated the early
90s with the little mermaid Beauty and
the Beast and Aladdin comes an absolute
stinker they kicked off more than a
decade of garbage
sucks guys yeah can you if you can bring
up that grid of films
um just to see what we what we included
on there
um I will say that no matter what your
personal feelings are uh no this movie's
underrated oh this one was actually
really good it was so bad that they just
stopped making animated films and fun
they just bought Pixar they just decided
that they couldn't do it themselves and
just gave up so that would have been
that good of all this list uh like I
don't really I can't even speak to like
Chicken Little or bolt I don't even
really remember those follow the range I
agree terrible Tarzan I feel like
probably defensible right Tarzan some
good songs some good songs yeah like I I
don't think that's one's a complete wash
but that's one that I do I did see and
just you know all I remember is the is
the Elton John stuff so I don't know no
one's yeah whatever I'm just gonna
antagonize them more I remember all the
Tony Hawk stuff that was like the big
thing was that it was like Tarzan is
like instead of swinging on ropes he's
gonna like get sick with it it's Phil
Collins not Elton John though whatever
that's actually much worse um but fine
it will be in his heart
uh yeah I uh it's it just wasn't for me
what can I say and yeah uh props to you
if you're if you're a Tarzan fan I just
if it was so good why did they stop
making cartoons
um so that's that's my counter to you
all right uh let's keep going but
they're back now sweet therapy is great
Pocahontas
Mead Pocahontas a product of Disney's
underage thirst trap era she's a
princess based on a real 12 year old sex
trafficking victim transformed into a
dry land version of Ariel I expect those
rules to be obeyed you disobeyed me
daddy I love him I love him father in
this all Leg Adventure that's just a
little mermaid without the catchy songs
sense of fun or knowledge that they're
all about to die from war feminine
disease but uh look over there
[Music]
um yeah man look up the starving time if
you want to want to know what it was
like back then wow the colonies
[Laughter]
it's not not a not a front not a fun
happy place for yeah either either of
these groups it was so bad and then it
was a lot of like uh yeah a lot of
murder a lot of famine
um
but I gotta say that you know this is
all kind of anecdotal I don't know how
much you can take this history at its
word but the the governor in this movie
John what's this
uh he was um captured and skinned alive
with mollusk shells wow
so sucks to be him
um just to really suck one of my least
uh like the place I would least want to
go with a time machine
um is colonial America so uh what's
yours sound off in the chat all right
keep going none yeah
Danielle's got like a thirty years in
Australia
to patronize an Indian
lives of savages all over the world
Savages he'll play John Smith a guy as
bland is the name John Smith would imply
I'm John Smith watch this Explorer
discover he has so much in common with
Pocahontas they're both hot it their
eyebrows don't match their hair color
and that's it for me in the 90s sister
as these two characters as thin and
two-dimensional as the cells they were
painted on find love during the time of
colonization a big goof up with plenty
of good people on both sides once two
sides want to fight nothing can stop
them in fact the English would be
friendly if it wasn't for One Bad Apple
in this historical epic that teaches us
all the real colonizer was love all
along London is that your village yes
buildings as tall as trees I'd like to
see those things see there she didn't
have to be kidnapped back to London who
said anything about her being kidnapped
if I don't know
the the historical story of Pocahontas
and John Smith
um has a like zero affection or
retelling in Native communities that
should really tell you all this that
like this is she's an icon for uh people
in and around Virginia a few hundred
years ago this is not like a famous
story otherwise and this Disney movie
they just turned it into like Romeo and
Juliet which it definitely was not
again it's just you go back to I I
totally get that in this era there was a
lot of talk about you know like we want
to diversify the Disney Princesses and
we want to you know like it they're all
white from the past and we want to be
the new which the 90s brother you know
like we're in the new Disney and so they
had done you know Belle and Ariel and
there was this is the era of Mulan and
they're gonna start trying to Branch out
more and good for them and so you get on
that level why the Pocahontas thing
might have been appealing but what but
like it's just not the the best story
just make up a new story you know like
it just feels like
there's got to be a way that you could
work Native Americans into the Disney
format without leaning on this actual
story that really happened it's not at
all appropriate for a kid's fan yeah
it's very much love conquers all and
then is the big takeaway and then
um you know the Conquering was just done
out of like sexual jealousy like oh she
can't be with him and he can't be with
her we want them yeah right yeah no this
is definitely like the kind of movie
that you could make before Wikipedia
existed right oh God can you imagine
fact checking a movie uh in 1995 going
to the library and like looking up a
card
In fairness this was also the version
that kids I I don't even know like this
was those version I was taught in school
is it like in elementary school like in
the 90s you basically had to read you
know Howard Zinn to get the real story
on this like it it's just much better
known today
in general the story of the colonization
of the Americas and like I feel like
younger people are just much better
versed in the sort of factual history of
this time than we were the United 90s
yeah when you're like yeah and I fell in
love and then you stopped being mean to
the natives you know and then they
shared their corn which they call maze
right you know
all right let's get going happened
when you're not stuck wasting time with
Pocahontas enjoy your time with equally
boring Side characters like three animal
Sidekicks more bumming than Bob jayback
wow
yeah this is way before the news when
this was written yeah I guess since we
don't do news uh uh these days why don't
you talk about uh Bob chapek out Iger in
what's what's your what's your uh quick
reaction to the news Danielle uh it
seems everybody I know that works in
animation super psyched about it yeah
you gotta take I mean I think it's it's
more it's it's like obviously traffic
messed up a bunch of things there was
the Scarlett Johansson stuff and then
the don't say gay bill in Florida kind
of side the parks all the park step
right like he's he's just kind of like
said a bunch of silly things like adults
don't watch cartoons that like the
Disney CEO obviously shouldn't say uh so
but I I feel like in a lot of ways he
was kind of still running the Iger
Playbook this is largely about
perception that like Iger is this iconic
figure who ran Disney for 15 years and
made all these huge deals he's the Pixar
deal guy the lucasfilm guy you know so
just having him be the one who's
steering makes people feel better which
is so important for a big public company
like Disney yeah
um I will just say that I didn't know
that
um not only do they share the same first
name they also shared the same middle
name what the hell is happening
yeah yeah wow uh really just pumping
them out
um okay the rumor is that uh eiger's
been like privately stewing about jpeg
doing a bad job for months now and then
but the thing I read was it was Friday
night like agar just like texts the
board all the time like oh this idiot
and then Friday night one of the board
members was like you just want to come
back and do it and he was like okay and
so all this is just the last few days
this all happened like all in the last
week yeah but it sounds like it was
brewing the fact that it seemed to come
as a surprise to everybody means that he
was not
um this this wasn't really super
orchestrated because like they he was
going to introduce Elton John at Dodger
Stadium and then they're like no you're
off stage you're not doing it Bob in
Tiger's Town now
um interesting well I'm just glad he's
not running for president
um all right I can't like read Hastings
on it did you see that no he's talked
about it uh publicly like uh like I
might get into politics um so really
Hastings the co-ceo of Netflix tweeted
like I'm disappointed I thought Bob I
would be a great president him in the
Rock and they probably they probably
went
um okay let's keep going
[Music]
a talking tree that's a little too
thorned up for Comfort I want to see him
again I want to see him again and he's
handsome too and a bunch of English
explorers all right I know we're taking
forever what else you gotta do
uh
do we think that this tree used to be a
human woman and that's why she's like
attracted to human men and like listen
sister let me tell you or do we think
this is just like the spirit that's in
this tree and she's just in an inner
species like plants can find humans
attractive
they thought about it as much as you did
I think that they thought
um you know when we make this point
later in the trailer that it's just like
oh let's just put in some magic stuff
like you know maybe Native American
folks can talk to trees and it's like
right I would just like I it seems like
she's presented originally as like an
ancestral Spirit of the forest which is
then weird when she becomes like a Mae
West character yeah she's very much her
grandmother that's what they say right
well they call her grandmother willow
but that could be a term of if that
doesn't necessarily mean birth
grandmother that could be a term of
affection but also we never meet her mom
right her mom's presumed dead or missing
yeah we know her dad is the chief but we
don't know what happened she could also
just be a tree another tree somewhere
he's half tree a full tree I mean
Pocahontas is half tree yeah maybe
that's how she learned how to speak
English that's very powerful that's true
she does magically learn English just
like like power of the wind yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
made Americans can learn languages from
the wind oh that's that's yeah just from
trees just like imagine how badly you
want to make out with this dude and then
your heart will give you the way also
I'm sorry those three animal characters
it's just the weirdest thing because
suddenly you'll be like in this really
dark song about like industrialization
and wanting to like murder a village and
then it'll be like Oh look The Bird is
kooky yeah a lot of that a lot of mixing
in the the Goof em ups of those three
little creatures it's definitely feels
like they had someone else come in and
be like we need to punch up so let's add
in more of this like yeah yeah there's
one in Hunchback I think really have
that feeling of like it feels like they
just had the storyboards out and like if
it went too serious for too long they
were just like Circle it in red and like
put quirky animal cute Antics here yeah
and like and that's a long-standing
Disney tradition but as far back as like
Cinderella at that movie's like 70 mice
yeah yeah
of so but it's so deliberate it's like
oh we're getting a little dramatic like
maybe the raccoon could fall down go
boom okay could use the other one as an
accordion yeah yeah he only weren't lost
at sea in the opening scene not a
thousand bloodthirsty Savages shall
stand in our way if any Indian tries to
stop me they'll blast him Savages could
be hiding anywhere do you think we need
some Savages these white men are
dangerous
so it's Thanksgiving revisit an animated
musical whose songs range from
forgettable
and my mind for the taking too
regrettable kill ourselves
or maybe two or three except about how
indigenous folks are mythical beings
with magical powers instead of actual
people who still exist
I think my tribe are Ordinary People so
pause this is um
our own Emma Fife doing her best Judy
[ __ ] uh
impersonation and uh we have a new music
producer helping us out uh David Benitez
I believe is is his name and I think he
uh first time out so far so good yeah
we're back in the parody song business
folks
um so I think
um what's coming out next year maybe the
live action Little Mermaid or something
will be oh yeah we'll be back
um but yeah I didn't know Emma had a had
a musical theater background so we said
all right give us a scratch track and
knocked it out of the parts yeah perfect
let's kick back and enjoy the Colors of
the Wind
and claim a land you think you can
explain
[Music]
but we are all imbued with super super
power
we know magic we are Druids I'm Amazed
I'm basically an X-Man or Avenger the
Heron and the otter I command
and if you cross me John you will
discover
I can walk into
[Applause]
[Music]
I could blow you from this Lion King as
Mountain I control the ancient forces of
the wind if you cross me then I will
grind your bones to dust until
you're just pieces
I can scatter
in the
way
the bravo bravo Emma and uh David well
done
um rap control she's still going oh
excuse me yeah yeah
um so pause uh yeah I thought that was
really the only one worth doing I know
Lon you said you worked in a theater so
you have this other one stuck in your
head a lot oh uh there's the uh anyway
the river but anyway Just Around the
Riverbend is the other one yeah that
that was like that had a brief lifespan
as like a Disney tune people I agree
though like the the other than Colors of
the Wind they're all kind of forgettable
and then that there's that terrible the
the mining one where it's like it's a
there's a play on like mine like aha the
land is mine for the taking and I'm
gonna dig a mine but it really bothers
me that the depiction of mining is
they're in a forest they're digging
holes in the forest which is like that's
not it's not how you mine you could pan
for gold in a river not mining but okay
but mine comes from the mountain you
gotta you gotta dig in the map I feel
like this is Elementary stuff I don't
know how the movie missed this one but
he's literally singing a song about
Mining and then lighting a cannon that
blows up a bunch of trees like that's
logging sir which is also what the
Jamestown Colony actually thought they
were go like that was the crop they were
going for that was the resources they're
going to cut down wood yeah they were
going to cut down Lumber they thought
they didn't end up getting to do it
because they ended up having to focus on
not dying but the plan was to go and
like cut down all these trees and send
the lumber back to make ships in England
that was what they thought they didn't
think they were gonna get rich off of
mine and gold they maybe you know yeah
well look you know Al Menken was coming
off just the most insane run of of
mermaid Beauty and the Beast Aladdin
yeah I think he wrote Newsies in there
somewhere oh yeah
with Ashman who have R.I.P had sadly
left us by this point and just the
future collaborators were just not we're
not on an Ashman we never got back to
that Lincoln Ashman high point I still
think Colors of the Wind is is up there
it can go toe for toe toe-to-toe with
any of those Disney songs but aside from
that yeah really not a not a standout
it's not an aladdin where it's like
every single it's like a pretty solidity
into uh you know part of your world or
whatever yeah bangers bangers bangers
yeah yeah and like the villain songs
have never been usually except for
obviously in Little Mermaid most of the
villain songs are always kind of like
I never liked them and P and again you
say anything about Disney cartoons and
people just like fall out of a Mickey
Mouse be prepared be prepared
let's just keep going just keep going
under the eye is absolutely destroys
sorry let's wrap this up The Maze Runner
John 90 day finance a year trash
Bandicoot colonial American Psycho this
toss me Chief of Staff it's Giving Tree
Wizards of the Coast
and exactly what TLC warned us not to do
there you go
think about it the first White
[Music]
going back is his only chance he'll die
if he stays here so it ends with Jon
heading back to England to treat his
gunshot wound by boat is anyone gonna
tell him
yeah that's a four months
oh you know go back to those expert uh
18th century London doctors yeah we must
remove the Torso yeah they're doing
they're doing like the Tolkien bit like
he needs our Elvish medicine but it's
like but English Medicine of this period
was not good like and it takes forever
to get there
that's all the boat problems yeah yeah
maybe like try to put a leech on it
trying to see how long it took to sail
across the Atlantic I probably should
have looked that up first several months
I don't know if it was four but it was
at least New York to the English
channels well this is in 1970 okay uh
we'll look this up later somebody in the
in the Q a tell us
several months in the what 1400s to to
1600 1600
s um all right
well there we go uh I think we have some
things that we cut and if they're ready
let's watch those now
windbreaker navatar The Last Airbender
agent Smith step away from the 14 year
old why don't you take a seat over there
lawful evil neutral evil chaotic Ebola
the Washington Commander
kakuma Matata
dude just marry Nakoma hot girl bummer
and stop or my mom's mom will Groot
let the white one in
the Jamestown Massacre
[Music]
did it again nothing but rocks and dirt
sir I'm shocked they didn't find any
gold after only digging in one place
just a short walk from the ocean it
seems like it'd be laying right there
there you go learn to mine
okay you're not gonna teach kids History
Fair I get okay the history is troubling
I understand at least they could learn a
little bit about my name it must have
just been for that Mind song word it was
that's what I'm saying it was just the
pun or they would have made the song
about logging because that was the truth
you know yeah
hmm
yeah yeah
um speaking of disgraceful stuff from
the 90s that we should never talk about
again John
K yeah wow
uh sorry I'm just distracted by this
slack message that I got that uh Billy
Corgan is in uh our office building
today what not sure why
not our not fandoms offices but the
building that fandoms shares the
greatest day the grade
[Laughter]
I wonder if we have wrestling stuff that
happens anyway yeah uh fascinating stuff
um so let's move on to uh q a so Trevor
copter coming in with some very helpful
information to answer lawn's question
from last week the day the clown cried
will be available in 2024. oh
still has a ton of restrictions but
it'll finally be out in the world so
yeah maybe it'll be you have to like
check into a booth at the Smithsonian to
watch it or something like that that's
one of those it's because there's a lot
of like Infamous movies that like we
don't even know if they still exist or
not but of all the infamous movies that
we know exist but people have never
gotten to see I think that's the most
infamous yeah
um Bruins fan 1144 says it would never
happen but how about a Inglorious
bastard style Pocahontas where the
natives drive them off and win in the
end hard R Tarantino level violence I
mean I feel like now that we're getting
some more Native American voices behind
the scenes and just starting I mean just
green shoots these days you know the
early these stages of it but eventually
it would be cool to see you know native
creatives get to do stuff like that you
know yeah I'd like to I'd like to see it
I mean I hate to say it but Mel almost
got there with Apocalypto you just got
to end it
yeah that's inter-indigenous violence
yeah that's like what one group of Inca
again yeah he's on the run from another
one
uh I'd watch it
um uh in the spirit of the holidays uh
what is your Mo FJ Prince what's your
most traumatic holiday
it's ours are lovely I haven't I I don't
think I've had a particularly traumatic
one
um you guys my family agrees with me
politically so I don't have that trauma
that people have every year of going
back and getting like fights with cousin
whatever I'm like I don't like we're all
liberals yeah
uh yeah no it's it's you know if it was
traumatic I'm not gonna share it here
because it's like really dramatic it's
like I love you guys but
uh
um nope a Reynard City update Channel
not reading that one oh wow
Mussolini cartoon about trains
um
yeah but props for trash
you know like like
yeah you wouldn't
troubling periods of History we just go
like well obviously you wouldn't do a
Disney cartoon about that but for some
reason the colonization of North America
was like okay but you see lawn the
minions were in a nice cave that's true
they're right the minions have to wait
out the 20th century for this exact
reason
um all right now finally uh we'll we'll
go back to the Bobs
um
uh uh my temple as he says even with
jpex sacked uh I feel like the 20s will
be the first time since the 80s where
Disney or Pixar is not at the top of
Western animation is it the spider verse
or is it has somebody else taken the
Disney Crown uh or or are they not I
mean I like I I would a little bit take
issue I I I love the spider verse this
is not a knock on spider verse that
movie kicks ass but yes I would not now
say that just based on the back of that
one movie that Sony is now the king of
Animation yeah
yeah I feel like Sony's at the maybe at
the start of they could build toward
that but to me right now it still kind
of feels like especially if you bring in
the Disney plus of it all
you know I mean there and there's other
people doing all like cartoon Saloon
that Irish outfit that like they just
had a new one come out my father's
dragon they're great they did Wolf and
whoever did Arcane uh the TV series yeah
yeah and like right anime I mean
certainly there's there's people doing
amazing stuff over there and there's a
lot of good animation on like Netflix
and you know whatever but like even
Amazon has invincible
that box Machina but um I don't I still
feel like it's probably Disney's number
one especially if you could find Pixar
and Disney Animation together yeah for
sure
The champ is coming come with the King
you best not miss
um so uh oh Disney animated stuff is
great says Nikolai yeah agreed
um maybe it'll get well maybe it'll get
better now that there's only like one
thing left they'll put all their
resources certainly Warner Bros
Discovery is taking themselves out of
the competition in a lot of ways yeah
yeah
uh well I know this might have uh seemed
um a little strange to go back to
Pocahontas but it is Thanksgiving so
your clue for next week is there's
really no reason to go back to it except
uh boy especially after re-watching it
there's no reason to yeah I guess it's
just look it was it was a holiday
scheduling thing I wanted to do the
Guardians holiday special but because of
stuff uh we we couldn't get to it so
next week is um a superhero afterthought
but maybe it'll be fun a huge movie
we've never done so just on that like
came out made a lot of money made waves
people remember it we've never done it
big stars in it there you go you're
selling it better than I could uh yeah
come come back next week and we'll all
get half cocked together that's a clue
maybe we'll be full by then uh we'll see
you then bye-bye
[Music]